on n'est pas une mine les frères on a
passé des mois à l'intérieur d'une bombe
ambulante qui raclent le fond des océans
c'est à cuirassé pas d'intervenir on
passe à des patins on va foncer droit
sur lui feu
torpillant d'un proche en battant 15-10
six capitaines remonter à fond toutes
parées pour un poste
nous assistons vos déploiement militaire
russe le plus agressif de son histoire
j'ai ordonné à ses hommes peuvent
envoyer un sous-marin d'attaqué
nous ordonne de traverser des manières
qu'aucun sous marin américain n'a encore
jamais traversé immergé l'appareil
[Musique]
on a surveillé le président russe et son
ministre de la défense
c'est un coup d'état et si on libérait
le président zacharie credo on sauve le
président russe on va y aller avec
quatre de nos gars ne sont pas entraînés
pour ce genre d'émission si on ne
réussit pas cette mission durera que
trois une guerre mondiale
c'est un cuirassé
torpillant approche pour poste et qu'on
adore vivre
ensemble pour lancer
je suis prête
e